Let's say that you're in
desperate need of money and I
have money to lend
to other people.
So this is me and this
is my gold chain.
So you come to me and say,
Sal, I need $10,000 for a
kidney transplant.
Can you lend me the money?
I'm in desperate need.
And I have $10,000.
Sure, I'm willing to lend it
to you, but it's a tough
economy and you never know where
that money's going to go
and I don't know if you're going
to be able to keep your
job after going through this
kidney surgery and all that.
So I'm very careful with my
money so I want to make sure
that you're good for it.
So we think about it a little
bit and I say, hey, that watch
you have on your wrist, that
looks pretty nice.
You say, this watch?
Let me draw the watch.
And I say, yeah, that watch.
You're like, this watch
I got from my
great-great-grandfather and it's
actually worth-- I don't
know-- maybe it's a diamond
studded Rolex of some sort and
it's actually worth
$30,000, right?
And I know that, clearly because
I've already become
well acquainted with gold and
diamonds and things like that.
So I say, I trust you and
you trust yourself.
I'll lend you the $10,000, but
just so that we all know that
everything's going to be fine,
why don't you just leave your
great-grandfather's
watch with me?
And when you pay back the
$10,000 with a low interest--
let's say it's 10% a week-- when
you pay back the money,
the principal, with the
interest, however long you
borrow it, I'll give you
back your watch.
You're like, I don't
know about that.
First of all, 10% a week
sounds like a lot.
I was like, well, don't you just
need it for the kidney
transplant tomorrow and then you
can work a couple of weeks
and then pay it back.
10% a week's not bad-- and we
all know that that is because
you compound that over the year
and it becomes some type
of horrendous interest rate.
But you're desperate.
You need your kidney and I'm
like, look, you plan on paying
me back, right?
So you're going to get your
$30,000 watch back, so what's
there to worry, right?
So why don't you just leave this
with me as collateral?
And you say, fine and you leave
your watch and you get
your kidney transplant and then
you try to work really
hard to pay it back,
but you never can
and I keep your watch.
And this is how the pawn process
essentially works.
You've pawned your watch off to
me, but in a less kind of
derisive way of talking about
it, you've given it as
collateral for a loan.
And I was willing to give you
the loan because I knew that
if you couldn't pay it back, I
could keep this nice asset.
And this happens all the
time in less shady
parts of our economy.
A bank will give you a loan and
they'll collateralize it
by the house.
If you can't pay the loan,
they keep the house.
They want you to put a down
payment on the house so that
even if the house devalues, they
still capture back most
of their money.
And so this is a pretty
straightforward
collateralized loan.
This is the collateral
you give me.
I give you the loan.
You pay it back.
I give you back the
collateral.
Now what if there was a reality
where I don't-- me as
the lender, I don't even like
this notion of collateral and
all of that.
I actually want to make it
very clear that I have
ownership of the collateral
when it happens, right?
I don't want some Feds coming
in and saying, wow, whose
watch is this that
you're holding?
Where's the receipt for this?
Where did you get it?
Was it stolen from somebody?
And it looks all shady and I
probably do have some side
shady operations anyway so I
want to know that I own this
watch in the event that
you don't come
back to pay the loan.
So instead, we could have done
this exact same transaction--
so this is you again.
This is me again.
I'll draw that top hat
and the moustache.
Those are my differentiating
characteristics, maybe the
gold chain.
And now what I can do is--
because I want ownership of
that watch, what I'll do is I
will buy that watch from you.
So you'll give the watch-- so
the watch will literally
change hands.
So I will buy the watch
from you for $10,000.
But we'll also have
a side agreement.
So far it's almost
identical, right?
The only difference between this
and what we did before
is, I'm actually selling
the money.
I'm actually buying the
watch from you.
This is a cash transaction.
This wasn't a loan, strictly
speaking, but the same thing
is happening, right?
Up here you handed
me the watch and
I handed you $10,000.
Here, you handed me the watch
and I handed you $10,000.
But what we'll add on to this
is an agreement that at some
future date-- so this is now.
We also going to have an
agreement-- and both of us are
parties to this-- that in the
future, I will agree to sell
and you will agree to buy this
watch for me for something
more than $10,000.
So in the future, you're going
to give me back my money.
So it'll be $10,000 plus
something-- and that's
something is essentially
interest, right?
So I'll get my money back
and then I'll give
you back the watch.
So if you think about it, this
is completely identical
economically to what we
did up here, right?
I gave you $10,000.
You gave me the watch
as collateral.
When you pay back the $10,000
plus interest, I give you back
the watch, right?
But at no time did I really
have real, legitimate
ownership of that watch.
Well, in this situation,
the same thing happens.
You come to me.
I give you money.
You give me the watch, but I
bought it from you so I have a
receipt too.
I am the official owner of the
watch while you have my money,
but we have an agreement that at
some future date, you will
repurchase the watch from me.
for $10,000 plus some amount,
which is essentially the
interest. So this was a loan
collateralized by a watch, but
the only difference here is that
instead of it just being
collateral, you actually sold
it to me and then we had a
repurchase agreement-- and it
took me six minutes to say
that, but I think it was worth
it-- where you agree to
repurchase the watch
at some point.
It's actually I'm the holder of
the repurchase agreement.
So the money lender-- so
I get the watch and
a repurchase agreement.
We'll call that a repo.
So these are two assets that I
now have-- the watch plus the
repurchase agreement.
You get the money.
And it's actually called
a reverse repo, from
your point of view.
But the whole idea here is this
agreement forces you to
buy the watch back at the
original amount that you
essentially borrowed from me
plus some interest. And this
essentially forces me
to sell it to you.
So we have a-- it's
essentially a forward contract.
A forward contract is just an
agreement to transact in the
future at some given price.
And the whole reason why I did
this is because this is how
the Fed transacts.
This is how the Fed lends,
especially with
the discount window.
Sometimes it's called a
repo transaction or
a repurchase agreement.
And so what the Fed does when
someone comes to it at the
discount window-- let me
actually draw proper balance
sheets now.
Let's say that this over
here is a bank in need.
I won't worry about the
right-hand side of the balance
sheet too much.
It has some liabilities,
some equities.
Let's say it has a
ton of assets.
Let's say that these right
here are treasuries.
But it's all out
of cash, right?
This is the bank.
It's all out of cash and on the
other hand, we have the
Federal reserve.
Let me see if I can draw their
balance sheet properly.
And the Federal reserve-- well,
for the most part, these
are going to be treasuries
right now.
It has some liabilities.
I won't go into that just yet.
It has some equity.
And let's say you're one
of these pariah banks.
No-one's willing
to lend to you.
Your depositors are taking
out their money.
So you need to convert some of
these treasuries into cash.
You don't want to just dump
them on the market.
Maybe there are other assets
that are less liquid and if
you just dump them, you won't
get the value you want.
So essentially you enter into
a repurchase agreement with
the Federal reserve.
So this is the Fed reserve.
You go to the Federal reserve
discount window.
The discount rate might be-- I
don't know-- 5% on an annual
basis, but we won't get into
the technicalities of that.
You say, hey, Fed, lend
me some money.
And the Fed says, OK, let me
print some money for you.
So these are the liabilities
notes outstanding and then he
prints some Federal reserve
notes, but instead of just
lending the money to you and
then keeping these treasuries
as collateral, the Federal
reserve will actually buy
these-- it'll enter into a
repurchase agreement with you.
So the mechanics of that is that
the Federal reserve will
buy these treasuries from you.
So now all of a sudden, the
treasuries-- the Federal
reserve notes will go from from
the Federal reserve to
you and then your cash will go
to-- then your treasury notes
will go to the Federal
reserve, right?
This is cash-- Federal reserve
printed cash, gave it to you,
and then essentially bought
treasury notes from you.
So now these are
treasury notes.
These are the treasury notes
that were here before.
But it has a repurchase
agreement where you agree at
some future date to unwind this
transaction, where you're
going to buy back your
treasuries and you're going to
pay the amount that the treasury
paid you initially
plus some interest, right?
So the basic way to view it
is, this was just a loan.
You just borrowed this much
from the Federal reserve.
The Federal reserve kept your
treasuries as collateral, but
it actually had formal
ownership over it.
And that's what differentiates
a repo agreement from just a
traditional collateralized loan,
but in the future you're
going to buy back those
treasuries for the amount the
Federal reserve had originally
bought them from you for plus
a little bit of interest. You're
going to pay a little
interest and that interest is
going to be dictated by the
discount rate.
Anyway, all out of time.
In the next video, we'll
actually look at the Federal
reserve's balance sheet.